who are the directors they are the
driving force of the motion picture
driven by vision by passion and also
every day by Teamsters they are the
organizing influence conductor guide
jack-of-all-trades mastermind
in short the one the producer blames in
the category of Best directing the
perpetrators are
background and action Ron Howard for a
beautiful mind Ridley Scott for Black
Hawk Down Robert Altman for gospel park
Peter Jackson the Lord of the Ring
electricity David Lynch Mulholland and
Oscar goes to Ron Howard
this is Ron Howard's first Oscar he
filmed a beautiful mind chronologically
which is a rare occurrence in filmmaking
thank you um well I am uh I'm not a good
enough actor anymore to be able to stand
up here and make you believe that that I
haven't imagined this moment in my mind
over the years and played it out about a
thousand times
so here goes it's a it's pretty simple
really uh I'm grateful I'm very grateful
for this I'm grateful for an entire
lifetime spent involved in this creative
process that we do I'm I'm grateful that
I was raised by an extraordinary man my
father Rance Howard and my late mother
Jean Howard I also want to mention that
before my mom passed away about eighteen
months ago she predicted that this was
going to happen for me on this film well
she also made that prediction on every
movie that I've directed since 1983 so
now you know a little bit something
about my mom thank you mom
uh then there are the loves of my life
uh my incredible wife Cheryl uh yeah
she's something
of kids at home Brice Jocelyn page and
read thank you for all the the most
important reasons I've got a great
friend and Anna and a partner Brian
Grazer Brian thanks for helping me
realize so many of my dreams in this
business including getting to direct a
beautiful mind which Brian produced so
passionately and Akiva Goldsmith
Goldsman wrote so brilliantly you know
everyone from from the decision makers
at Universal and then DreamWorks through
to the entire production team thank you
for the incredible effort it made the
difference and of course I had a
tremendous cast this is an acting movie
and including Jennifer Connelly and
Russell Russell Crowe this would not be
happening tonight without your creative
courage and your total commitment has
been a great journey I thank you
and finally either they're here
somewhere I don't know where but but
thank you to John and Alicia Nash for
six sharing your important story with us
I'm very very proud to know you and may
you have many years of peace ahead of
you
Academy thank you so much